heute lebt das video wirklich mit tumor
gewonnen jetzt zwar aber vieles im video
ist halt so spaß sowie nach ihr versteht
das schon deswegen schild viel spaß
jetzt und das natürlich jetzt schon mal
die 10.000 likes drin
intro
jo alex beh g8 weiter alex hallo auf den
du wolltest tor machen man was ist
gruppe auf die uralte ich will hat was
im spiel haben wir nur 15 oder so geht
da noch bis zum 18
hochladen besteht auf man wahrscheinlich
schon tags mittwoch leute was geht ab
herzlich willkommen beim neuen video
heute steht an ich zeige euch meine neue
wohnung in spanien ich hab mir gedacht
zu kommen egal ob jetzt von deutschen
aus videos oder von spanien ist
eigentlich egal weil ich meine jetzt das
wetter schön hier sind die leute schön
und hier habe ich einen tollen
mitbewohner namens julia und deswegen
gibt es halt eine kleine route was heißt
der kleine hund ohne xxl vum tour ich
zeig euch mein neues zuhause
und ja da will ich sagen
fangen wir doch mal an wir befinden uns
gerade in meinem zimmer tolles
dollar-raum gefällt mir sehr
tolle badehose kühlschränke hier ist
noch mein koffer aber auch schon meister
geht jetzt aus wie lange bist du schon
was zu seinen zehn oder so das ist hier
mein baby ums zimmer hier habe ich meine
lieblingsbücher mit dem aus deutschland
wie zum beispiel die terminator ein
tolles buch kann ich ihnen empfehlen
aber das auch gar nicht so wichtig wir
gehen weiter ganz speziell leute
folgendes bei mir so das problem
ich brauche wirklich von montag bis
freitag jeden tag ein anderes bad darf
ich wieder kommen richtet sich doch
einfach fünf ball zu meinen ich habe
mich einmal 25 und zwar an
film was hier im ersten mal ganz nach
toiletten duschen waschbecken und
waschmaschine die funktioniert komplett
automatisch ist die beschlusslage kurz
meine haare machen kurz meine haase
gehen wir einfach mal in das dienstags
bad rein in die stadt spart haben wir
eine badewanne morgen noch ein richtig
geiles video in der badewanne könnt ihr
euch schon mal drauf freuen
und jetzt machen wir mal kurz meine
haare es gibt hier nicht so weiter
machen nämlich immer die feuchtigkeit
unabhängig ja das hier ist mein
dienstags bach dann würde ich sagen
kommt meist auch schon direkt zum
mittwoch bat das hier ist das mittwochs
bad gefällt der hammer halte die haben
wir eine ganze mannschaft wieder in
waschbecken toilette wenn wir hier
weiter gehen kann man zum donnerstag
start
und wenn man hier weitergehen sind wir
auch direkt wieder in freytags mal zu
lassen
meine fünf waren zumeist nichts
besonderes hat eigentlich jeder
und jetzt kommen wir so einen weiteren
schönen zimmer und zwar ist das hier
mein yahoo-aktie nichts macht einen
super toller fernseher gleichzeitig noch
mein roller der pflicht die stafette so
130 km/h 130.000 aufhören mein helm ist
ganz wichtig dass zeige ich euch gleich
hier haben als erst noch mein
arbeitszimmer das ist hier der laptop
vom juni das ist mein laptop gebe jeden
tag geschnitten was das zeug hält damit
ja auch immer was zu sehen hat den kamin
damit uns bei 38 grad im schatten auch
nicht kalt wird
da ist übrigens der außenbereich ist ein
uralter die küche
bücher weg supertolle kühlschrank
coladosen pepsi dose tortilla chips
tipps ersten schuss noch an chips hier
ist die kühltruhe pizza und so ist darin
ein ofen super toll lacht das ist auch
komplett langweilig oder durch das mal
danach ihr zimmer vom juni naja ich so
aufgeräumt
hier sind unsere nachbarn dar und
familie sanchez fernando torres und
familie
fernando ricardo perez und da wohnen
familie pablo ricardo fernandez tores
die heißen ja alle gleich aber sind sehr
sympathische menschen ja so läuft jetzt
will ich sagen kommt mal stellt auf die
terrasse das echten precious ding hier
hier ist ganz normalen tisch schöner
drastischer ist der 5008 also wer saß
teilige heute schon pizza gegessen super
und hier sitze ich jeden abend und gucke
mir die schöne aussicht alle leute gebt
euch mal diese geile aus ich finde das
geil so klar
mehr wer aus schild aber ich finde die
berg das einfach mal was anderes ist
voll geil oder nicht was meinst waren
wir hoch laufen die berge dann gucken
nein besser nicht mit blödel zu hoch
viel zu faul so viel zu unserem
außenbereich hier frühstücken wieder
jeden morgen hier essen wir jeden morgen
abend wenn wir nicht in irgend einer
x-beliebigen burger bude kommen
hallo
naja egal ich zeige euch mal den
außenbereich erwarten wo sind die
schlüssel für rolle ja leute die haben
wir ganz exotische früchte würde ich
gerne mal anbieten
das hier sind nicht giftige kleine äpfel
hat wirklich gegessen hatte eine schöne
palme wächst auch in deutschland nicht
deswegen ist auch mit ausschlaggebender
faktor warum ich hierhin gereist bin so
jetzt gehen wir mal zu unserem geil
allein schon meine hose darstellt so
richtig für den spanischen lifestyle und
einkleben keine drogen auf jeden fall
hier das ist das wichtigste damit wir
hier auch immer weg um unser oder der
heißt rolle bei den namen genannt und
hier kommt der so wichtig hier noch
gebaut
so leute jetzt kommt das wichtigste
schließlich vor dem schlüssel passt auch
das sind helm dürfe ein held tricks
helme szenen für eine solche sicherheit
zumal das wichtigste
eine runde
chillig oder
dass fernando torres und kassiert hätte
auch noch ok ja kann man auch immer das
zeigen ja leute auch noch ein geiles
stück hier das ist der grill
das gute an dem ist der dreh die
würstchen selber ganz von alleine
keine ahnung wie das macht aber er kann
das und hier haben wir noch unsere
automatische bewässerungsanlage oder wir
haben uns gestern sind wir hier lange
gang und plötzlich das so gemacht und
mir dachte die sind schlangen drin und
dann haben wir sehen der bewässert
einfach automatisch
hier geht es einmal um
jetzt befinde ich mich wieder hier oben
auf der terrasse ich würde sagen es war
es erstmal so mit den wichtigsten dingen
hier
es ist übels war ich glaube es sind
gerade ungelogen 36 grad oder so und ich
schwitze mega wenn euch das video
gefeiert und wir sagt ja das ist schon
cool hier würde ich mich selber ein
daumen nach oben freuen
und ja das war es dann soweit erst mal
ab so der ju remix auch nochmal mit
daher kommt ja leute das ist der juli
der ist auch dabei
er macht auch youtube-videos und zwar
also ich hab den alex wir sind hier ja
schon zwei tage ich habe den alex lässt
den ganzen letzten tag 24 stunden lang
getränk das ich habe ihn als kind hab
ich ihn genervt werden im schlafen bin
ich rein gerannt habe lustige faxen
gemacht wird eine komplett dumm
eigentlich aber gut habe ich gesagt so
oder willst du weiter erzählen
ich würd mal sagen der juli hat noch
nicht so lange mit youtube angefangen
hat ist so 3000 abonnenten ich verlinke
euch den channel von ihm ganz oben in
der video beschreibung und wenn das
ganze bei 7 bei 8008 28 tausend
abonnenten leder das hoch also ihr
kommen auch wirklich coole videos von
new deswegen abonnierten auf jeden fall
und auch videos mit mir
jak luis channel ab und dann kommt links
punkt hier frank zeugs ist mega geworden
also freut euch drauf und ja jeden fall
kommen videos beweisen kann er morgen
kommt das heftigste video oder morgen
das video das sieht heftig wie wird das
video morgen bauleute es ist so fucking
waren wir müssen jetzt irgendwie ins
meer oder so keine ahnung hat rein
das meer ist ein bisschen von hier aber
das juckt uns überhaupt nicht denn wir
fahren mit unserem roller berlin ots ps
daumen nach oben nicht vergessen folgten
auf installieren
ich bin voll euphorisiert hochrhein bis
morgen